quel monde après la crise planétaire du
coc vide 19
[Musique]
comment consommer est-ce que les est
adoptée lors du confinement vont rester
comme celui des circuits courts par
exemple un moyen d'éviter les
hypermarchés et de soutenir les
agriculteurs
est ce que vous croyez au jir kilgour de
la viande
de tout temps il y a eu de la vente
directe mais plus les années passent
plus la façon de consommer des français
évoluent avec le développement des
grandes surfaces
conséquence au début des années 80 les
agriculteurs sont en difficulté pression
des centrales d'achat concurrence
étrangère il faut trouver une solution
et la vente directe et évoqué une des
motivations de ses ventes
c'est de pouvoir discuter à la le
consommateur car nous n'avons pas
toujours pas toujours très bien vu
lorsque nous ferons des manifestations
et que nous barrerons la route les gens
ne comprennent pas pourquoi alors par ce
biais là nous nous pouvons dialoguer
avec eux la chambre d'agriculture du var
prend les choses en main en lançant
l'opération vente directe des produits
de la ferme
une première en france à si grande
échelle le but permettre aux producteurs
de vendre le fruit de leur récolte au
juste prix
disons que les agriculteurs connaissait
des problèmes économiques importants sur
leurs exploitations
ils sont amenés à travers certains types
de production à accéder au marché direct
et à ne pas passer par les circuits
traditionnels
ce qui leur permet de récupérer une
certaine partie de la plus-value
les producteurs sont autorisés à vendre
leurs fruits et légumes directement à la
ferme ou sur des stands au bord de la
route
chaque année l'opération vente directe
des produits de la ferme et renouveler
et elle s'étend même aux départements
voisins
le gard l'hérault la vente directe sur
les stands incite même certaines
exploitations à se repenser dès lors
qu'il a eut découvert en 1980 les vertus
du stand cet agriculteur à orienter la
polyculture en fonction de la demande
même si elle n'a pas résolu les
problèmes agricoles
lié à la conjoncture la vente directe a
indéniablement constitué pour le
propriétaire n'a point non négligeable
et dès le début les consommateurs sont
conquis tout pour moi une question de
fraîcheur pour ça rit ça marche et que
tout le monde des arts nous a touchés
tous bon une fois qu'ils arrivent que le
transport et toucheront sarine moins de
frais plus frais plus directe et parfois
même moins cher une consommation
repenser à l'échelle locale qui a fait
son retour avec les contraintes imposées
lors du confinement
certains veulent croire que ses
habitudes deviendront pérenne ou
faudra-t-il attendre une autre crise
[Musique]